hey in this video I'm gonna be sharing
with you a case study from our business
that has been incredibly powerful I
believe that this is one of the most
powerful marketing trends right now and
if you implement this in your brand and
your business you can 10 extra impact
and your revenue and I'm gonna break it
down step by step but hey if you're new
to this channel this is think marketing
my name is Sean kennel I wrote a book
called YouTube secrets I run a company
called think media and on this channel
we get in the nitty-gritty this is the
behind the scenes this is kind of like
where we open up the hood the case
studies the results and really the best
online marketing strategies so that you
can get more customers you can get more
leads even if you're just new to
building an online business this is the
kind of information that's gonna give
you an edge and so hit the like button
if you're grateful to be here today and
I want to jump right into the training
that I have for you this is what we're
gonna be talking about we're gonna be
talking about the newest marketing trend
in 2020 and how to 10x your impact and
revenue right now and I'm gonna share
this is really fresh because we just
finished this up but here's the answer
and then I'm gonna break down ten things
that I've learned from doing this and
its challenges its challenges online
challenges to grow your business and
make a greater impact in the lives of
people now this is not social media
challenges like the planking challenge
like the one where you eat all the
marshmallows or where you do something
weird in social media know these are
transformational challenges that you can
host online no matter who you are I saw
Greta here you can do a increase your
golf swing challenge right and so I
actually really want to challenge you to
consider doing a challenge soon and I'll
tell you why but what exactly is a
challenge well you could do a 30-day
workout challenge you could do a
seven-day social media challenge maybe
learning how to do social media you
could do a five-day writing challenge in
fact tell me in the comments what is
your niche if you were even in gaming
you could do like a how to increase your
APM come on
Starcraft 2 anybody know what I'm
talking about actions
per minute how to get better at your
craft you know three days if you're in
marketing a Facebook Ads challenge you
could do like a detox and cleanse
challenge they could be at any different
lengths and what people do is you host
these challenges in a Facebook group you
host it in daily zoom calls you host it
on stream yard maybe like this on
YouTube or whatever it could be a build
your confidence challenge it could be a
payoff debt challenge let's create a
debt snowball come on Dave Ramsey it
could be a shoot your first YouTube
video challenge it can be learned the
Bible friends of mine so the Poppy
channel saying create a movie in five
days really smart Mike's here online
course creation it could be like that
get your mini course created in a
weekend challenge you know
Steph's here good to see chronic illness
it could be get up get ahold of your
health again a challenge and let me know
if you were a part of our wheat recent
YouTube influence challenge because it
was so powerful in fact look at just a
fraction of some of the results that
people said all the sessions were like a
jolt to my heart but I have to say the
women on YouTube was powerful to my
destiny Missy said that
we did a women's panel about YouTube
this challenge was so awesome
Nakia said what an awesome week gray
said I'm behind with the challenges but
I recorded yesterday have learned so
much and I'm inspired thank you Sean in
the think team Becca said finally
learning how to do business the right
way while still pursuing my passion
making a difference in the world like
you said Sean money is not the root of
all evil the love of money is money is
absolutely a tool to help you navigate
life and fund your business or something
my aha moment was when we talked about
strategy community psychology can you
say my mind was completely blown x'
brittany said so we got countless
messages like I've got folders and
messages and to be clear this is exactly
what we did so and I want to share a
resource because Sean where did you
learn challenges I didn't make this up
it was actually my friend Pedro and he
and I are gonna be doing a free class
and there's a link to that in the
description below because I was like
Pedro dude I didn't know this was gonna
be that crazy bro like I want to pass
along to our community so if you want to
see anything about that there's a link
in the description but I saw that he was
doing challenges he's got about 30 and
so naturally I was like what kind of
training do you have what kind of
resources do you have can you help me in
the think media team learn even what a
challenge is let me know if you've ever
heard of challenges like this before let
me know if you've ever been a part of
one of like this before and I don't
really know how they worked and so what
we came up with was the 7 day YouTube
influence challenge what we did was we
built a private Facebook group from
scratch like we just started one from
scratch and we actually did two
trainings a day that was a little overly
ambitious so every day I went live with
a couple other people in the think media
team at 10 a.m. in the morning and then
usually we went live at 5 p.m. all
Pacific time I'm based here in Las Vegas
and every single day we did training and
then there was like actions to do like
today come up with some video ideas
today design your thumbnail today shoot
your channel trailer so that's kind of
the power of a challenge is it's not
just information it's transformation and
it's getting people to take action and
here's what's so crazy about this
challenge was we ended up with 19
thousand two hundred and eighty three
people that joined the Facebook group
that's nuts now obviously I've been you
know I've got think media and I've been
doing YouTube for a while and so we've
have some you know organic influence and
maybe people that already know us right
this is not like day one for me but at
the same time we had so many new people
discover us because of this challenge
and we actually spent a lot of money in
facebook ads on this channel think
marketing this is where we can talk
about digital marketing where we could
talk about and Instagram ads where we
could talk about the essential tools of
modern marketing and so again I want to
give you 10 things that I learned and I
saw as a result of this challenge but if
you think you'd want to do a challenge
check out this free class it's not
learned with thing calm link in the
description below my friend Pedro a Deo
is who broke it down and taught me how
to do
and it's a it's a really powerful way to
find new customers quickly grow your
brand and channel and create a movement
based business that's what I think that
is so powerful about challenges is it's
really for Purpose Driven entrepreneurs
and heart-centered entrepreneurs that
really want to impact people's lives and
make a difference in people's lives
while at the same time realizing that to
sell us to serve that to offer products
programs and services and let people go
to deeper level with you is simply to
serve at a higher level that it's
ethical to serve to sell its ethical
when you've got a transformational
product but at the same time people can
come through a challenge and even with
just a free challenge by the way and by
the way people do pay challenges
sometimes people my friend Pedro did a
31-day wisdom challenge and it cost $31
so it was one dollar a day and he
actually had guest speakers the entire
time and it was going through the 31
chapters of The Book of Proverbs so like
there's so many different ways to do
this and if you're interested I
encourage you to check out that class
but here's 10 things that this challenge
did for our business the number one this
was by far the biggest momentum builder
in our business that's ever happened by
far like easily it was chaos - like
don't let I'm not here to say that this
was just like a walk in the park it was
exhausting it was it was like a labor of
love man it was like pouring out energy
and not just myself but it was so
encouraging that the think media team
people you've met like Heather Taurus
and Melissa Caputo and Tony Arriola
and the rest of the team that's helps on
customer service and all kinds of things
it was it was a lot of energy was it
easy no was it worth it you got to be
kidding it was so powerful and so it was
the biggest momentum builder in our
business the power of a challenge is
it's almost it's like focus intensity if
you've ever heard about the momentum
theorem like focused intensity over time
builds momentum you know so it's about
like having a few days of really getting
momentum for what is your niche you know
getting momentum in your golf game
getting momentum in your finances
getting momentum in your health getting
momentum in your spiritual life these
are the types of things
people were doing and so just built so
much momentum it's like a rising tide
lifts all ships and so it wasn't just
the fact of the challenge it was like
we've got other podcasts and other
projects that were working on YouTube
channel it like lifted everything that
we were doing number two it was the
biggest Community Builder that we've
ever done in terms of again building
community and in connecting with other
people look at what Steven said this is
more valuable than semesters at college
Smith's encouraging it's amazing man
let's see thank you guys for all the
time and effort you've dedicated to
educating us Tony said this so so much
care about us without even knowing us
I've learned so much and so many aha
moments in every session you are all
amazing god bless and thank you crooked
hat Matt past few years have been pretty
rough for me so I wanted to let you guys
wanted to let you guys for open so I
wanted to let you guys for opening up
his challenge has easily been one of the
most helpful and powerful things in my
life like listen to these comments is
crazy thank you guys thanks to all I
wish the best success to think media and
the entire team for your generosity and
coaching teaching us the wonderful
information for your big hearts be
blessed the thing I love about being
here is the positivity the structure
teaching and the eagerness to uplift and
help losing through every session so
massive community building like meeting
new people but then building a bond
number three it was an accelerator of
know like and trust if you ever want to
be in business you have to understand we
do business with people we know with
people we like and then with people we
ultimately are able to build trust with
so a lot of times the marketing process
can be a really long process somebody
sees one social media post they get you
know a flyer from your business in the
mail they they see a billboard they get
a Facebook ad one time and they don't
see another thing for a couple weeks so
it can take like a really long time to
build know like and trust the power of a
challenge is it's an accelerator of that
process by the way if you want to build
a YouTube channel you want to build you
know a podcast you want more customers
you need people to know
like you need awareness and so it was a
powerful way of getting people to know
us
then they got see look it's up to them
if they're gonna like us or not not
everybody's gonna like you but they need
to even give them a chance to like you
right
and so then ultimately they could trust
you they see you're good for it whatever
and then you're able to say if you
enjoyed this there's a next level you
can go to number four it was the biggest
growth of new people discovering my
brand in a two week period ever I've had
a viral video so I guess you could say
that it got like 2.3 million views you
could say that more people discovered my
brand like maybe saw my face but they
don't really discover my brand that's a
mistake we make I think with with the
desire to go viral is viral is in your
newsfeed and gone the next moment it's
on your youtube homepage and then it's
gone the next moment we don't
necessarily connect with a viral video
we see and are exposed to a viral video
the people that raised their hand and
dove into this challenge it was like
this accelerator of people really
understanding who think media is Who I
am what our brand is about how we want
to help people how we want to serve
people the mission that we're on number
five it was the greatest increase in the
strength of the think media brand I kind
of just said that people didn't really
realize that this is not just Sean
Connell but there's like a whole team
here that's on a mission to help 10,000
people create a full-time living doing
what they love while making a difference
in the world with online video and that
we've got like ninja YouTube strategists
like Tony aureola
or like Melissa Caputo that we've got
entrepreneur lady bosses like Heather
Taurus and that we had like the tech
team come on and Nola know more and so I
think that even though we put a lot of
stuff out into the marketplace you might
think I've got a website that says my
mission of my values I've put out
YouTube videos that have explained who I
am and what I'm trying to do in the
world that doesn't mean people have
watched it let alone that they've
understand it let it let alone that
they're even really paying attention
people got so many problems of their own
it's hard to actually even really build
real awareness about what you're up to
like for the pastors in our community
like when you have a vision for your
church and a mission for your true you
can't just say that one time like you
have to say it over and over and over
again and people don't necessarily know
what your vision your mission is what
you're about so this is an accelerator
of I our brand of like the mission think
media is on number six it was the most
powerful team-building accelerator we've
ever done so you may just be a
solopreneur right now a solo creator let
me know hit like if you're getting value
out of this video too but and you might
not have a team but if you do have a
team or a couple people would help you
with this or do you have administrative
assistants or you know V A's or anything
it cause it's all the level up man we
all had to grow it was like pressure and
pressure is a good thing like pressure
makes diamonds you one of the reasons
why you might not be growing as much as
you want is you're not under enough
pressure
you know if you want your muscles to
grow you need to put them under pressure
come on for the bodybuilders in my
community clearly I've put no pressure
on my biceps lately and therefore
they're not getting bigger if you want
to get bigger in your business and your
revenue and your subscribers and your
influence you got to have more pressure
so too much would be not good because
you could get injured but it was cool to
see I knew the leadership of our team
and they just and thought I think they
can rise to the occasion and they
exceeded my expectations
it built their confidence it built more
team unity it built more buy-in to the
mission you know during this challenge
what we did was we actually taught
through our proprietary process of the
seven R's of youtube influence the seven
video ranking Academy R so we just did a
seven day challenge we taught one of
these a day and I'll be honest like even
our own team didn't probably know these
as well as I thought they did come on
that's humbling as a business owner so
it just was an accelerator of so many
different things so let me know come on
Jess Samson reps reps reps and so such
is such a powerful challenge so anyways
um I got a couple more for you but I
have some stuff to teach you for sure
but really my friend paid
was who broke down exactly what I should
do step by step so if you are curious
about how to run a challenge it's kind
of last minute because I was just like
hey bro can we do a like a free class
and he has of course - on challenges but
either way if you had are at all
interested in this then check that out
it's that learn with think calm and I
think what's kind of powerful is not
only do you find new customers but you
can quickly grow your brand and channel
overall awareness of everything and then
also create a movement based business I
think again the best marketers in modern
marketing as far as the new trends and
marketing are people that create
movements you know if you think about it
like TOMS shoes although I think they're
going bankrupt but you know you think
about Patagonia or you just think about
different brands Tesla even are people
that are creating movements you're part
of a bigger mission you you don't want
to make as much impact you don't want to
harm the earth with carbon emissions you
want to be on the forefront of
technology these are movement makers and
I think that's how you need to think
about yourself like I want to start a
movement with my business I want to sort
a movement with my brand I want to start
a movement movement doesn't have to be a
million people you've probably read the
article and if you haven't look it up
later on a thousand true fans that
really it takes a thousand true fans to
be able to do this full-time as an
artist as a creative as an entrepreneur
that's a thousand like kind of diehard
customers or diehard people that are
like I'm bought in I'm on this mission
with you and so this is one of the best
ways to do it and so there's a again
register for that and I got a couple
more tips for you mike says the business
is that have survived the great pause
are the ones that have community and
build movements well put Mike the
businesses that are better making it and
so why do a challenge right now a couple
reasons every the reason I've just
listed but also people have more
attention online right now they're
consuming more content let me know if
you're locked down tell me in the
comments are you still locked down you
know I think people we've all paused so
much as Mike said the great pause we've
all had more time
to think about our goals think about our
dreams think about our future think
about our ambition so when you put out a
challenge that is what certain people
will resonate with I want to grow my
youtube channel or I want to lose weight
or I want to get out of debt that
resonates with people and they have the
time right now and even though the
lockdown has been you know softened a
little bit at some places people still
have time and so Steph's still locked up
and that's probably why so hey soos I
just dropped a link in the live chat
it's also in the description you go to
learn with think comm which is just a
redirect link to the challenge class and
that link is in the description down
below and so a couple more things though
that we learned the number 7 biggest
accelerator of deeper connections with
current community members we
overestimate how much our subscribers
our current community members are even
that connected to us we just think like
oh yeah I got you know a thousand people
on my email list I got 10,000 people on
my email list doesn't mean they even
really know who you are again eventually
email them and they're like don't
message you and they'll be like why did
you steal my email they'll be like what
are you what are you doing stop spamming
me and you're like I've never stolen
anybody's email you signed up for this
but here's the thing
they literally forgot that they signed
up like that's a thing they're like wait
a minute
who's you steal my email from like dude
the only way I have your email is if you
signed up on a page at some point but
that's how quickly we can be forgotten
and I don't blame them because how many
things have you signed up for you wanted
to go do you wanted to go watch that
clout you want you know what I mean and
then two three four weeks go by or a
year goes by and you're like who's that
chick again you know what I mean they're
like who's that dude like why is he
emailing me all the time like what's
going on challenges are a huge
accelerator to build deeper connections
with current community members so people
that are maybe in your world but kind of
on the fences it's just like a focused
intensity time for people to really get
locked in again so it can like
reinvigorate a current email list you
have or even current YouTube subscribers
in a way it's kind of like doing 30
days of a YouTube video every day but a
little bit different because you're
inviting participation and you're
helping people take action to get a
result and to solve a problem that they
have here's a tip challenge your
challenge should solve a problem it
should go after one problem ours was how
to build your influence on YouTube
your challenge so what's an idea of a
challenge you could do like in your
niche what is something that you could
watch or be a part of pilot vlog says I
loved your seven-day challenge it
created a fun community so that's really
cool to see that feedback and and let me
know what's an idea you have like I see
Evan here it could be like a seven-day
or three-day get better at music
challenge or worship music or to learn
certain songs or to learn how to play an
instrument it could be a lot of
different things Matthew getting people
to take action and make a song challenge
that like each day I don't know about
making a song but we're gonna do like
the bassline we're gonna do like the
melody we're gonna do an ad on the other
elements or whatever it is seven days to
cheaper insurance that's that's really
good or and maybe it could be like even
seven days and even it could even be
three days it could even just be like
identifying your insurance needs because
maybe it's like day one what are your
where what are your vulnerabilities you
know of in insurance day two how can you
save money on in insurance and then like
day three the best you know whatever so
it doesn't always have to be seven but
by the way some people do them longer
some to do them shorter a five day get
closer to Christ challenge I love that
something that could help people take
action Evan
yeah becoming better leaders nine day
get going in golf challenge brilliant
ideas and so a couple other things that
it did number eight this was the most
free value training knowledge and
coaching we've ever given away and I was
afraid of that let me know if you ever
want to create a course or something if
you've been afraid and even wonder like
how much free information should I give
away we taught for over thirty hours for
free
by the way I kinda don't recommend doing
a seven-day to add a session challenge
to start I had no idea what I was
getting into this our first challenge
ever you know bit off more than I could
chew kind of my personality I
Thanksgiving do you ever take
do you ever overload your plate at
Thanksgiving do you ever do two plates
that's when you really know you got a
problem that's me right I got literally
I'm like oh shoot this I need a salad
plate because cuz all the turkey and the
mashed potatoes and the and the
cranberry sauce you know my eyes are
bigger than my stomach a lot so so as
you think about doing a challenge like
legit I'd recommend you do like a
three-day one first you know we were
gonna do a five-way done wine it turned
into a seven day one we did bonus days
then it was like eight or nine days and
so you live and you learn but it was so
amazing yes I'm even still tired I mean
we just finished it up last week but so
powerful it was the most free value
training knowledge and coaching we've
ever given away and it impacted so many
people and here's what was cool is we
got messages from people that were like
I've just been laid off
like I can't invest in any other
training I can't go do anything else
right now
but you just changed my life with this
free information and when I get a job
again or when my husband's employed
again or when we're in a different
season like we're connected now and and
I'm just so grateful for you but we
can't even do business with you right
now how powerful is that like no
pressure you know but some people were
like wow you gave so much free value I'm
excited to join your next thing or be a
part of how to go deeper with you like
in our program video ranking Academy so
it was the most ever free valued
training knowledge at coaching we've
ever given away but it also generated
the most revenue in our business in a 14
day period that we've ever done to a
multiple of 10x and that's the problem
the promise of this title was that it
was shockingly like I mean this whole
thing I was like dude what Pedro has
taught me is so powerful because like to
think of a day in business we always
feel weird is it like do we make an
impact or do we make a profit like those
two things have to fight against each
other no those two things can actually
be friends
you can make a difference in people's
lives while making a significant living
in profit at the same time now it's like
the unlock like Wow and because it
generated more revenue in a 14 day
window than we've ever seen and think
media history to the tune of 10x while
at the same time generating more
goodwill and more impact than we've ever
seen I mean I can't even go into all of
these but like when I look at we just
tried to capture as much as we could
about you know the impact it's made I've
been making videos for almost a year and
you guys are providing so much advice I
really appreciate the experience you
can't really see these but this is just
like all of the some of just a fraction
of the kind of screenshots of some of
just the testimony every single day on
every session but listen there's one
other thing that was so powerful too is
we also did a lot of ad spend in terms
of investing in Facebook Ads
Instagram ads to promote the challenge
and we actually had positive row as
before the challenge started roh-roh as
return on adspend
roas return on adspend
hey it's think marketing we're talking
about marketing terms so think about
this like if you're gonna invest in like
Facebook Ads
and this is what we used to do in the
past you know we would spend money to
get somebody to join the email list be a
part of something and then eventually
make a sale but sometimes we wouldn't
actually make an offer for a week or two
or three later
and so we would spend all this money up
front and we wouldn't even know if the
offer was gonna be successful or not and
there's been times we've lost we're like
we either broke even when and by the way
when you break even as a business owner
you lose money because I'm like why pay
people I like have expenses and so
breaking Heathman is not the goal you
know you're trying to you're in business
to make a profit so we had positive
return on adspend
before the challenge even started and
that's 100% because of the way we set it
up how we structured it and so anyways
throughout this video biggest momentum
builder biggest Community Builder
biggest accelerator of no
like entrust biggest growth of new
people discovering our brand if you are
getting inspired I encourage you
research challenges and give it a shot
like figure it out
and if you want to go a little bit
deeper we're doing the class pretty soon
with Pedro I'm doing a live training we
are gonna do some Q&A we'll leave the
replay up because this was all just in
response to me just being like dude this
is crazy man like thank you for the
advice the wisdom for giving me the
framework for giving me the tips and I
think that's the shortcut you know what
we teach what we believe is that you
know there's two ways to get ways done
one is your own mistakes - is somebody
else's mistakes it is always smarter to
go further faster by learning from
somebody else so Pedro a day oh my
friend is who I learned this from and so
we're doing a class and it's gonna be a
lot of fun and so we actually are a part
of a prayer group together of
entrepreneurs and so he's known as the
challenge guy and he's had a crazy
results and he's really known and kind
of like the clickfunnels world and
whatnot so we're jumping on a class and
you can there's a link to it in the
description below if you want to learn
more about this or just go to learn with
think calm and it's gonna be a lot of
fun it's happening in like a couple
hours but if you're watching this on the
replay we're going to leave the replay
up because I know that's kind of a short
time frame and so bottom line one of the
best ways to build momentum in your
business right now in 2020 and one of
the best ways to market and build a
movement and make a difference is
challenges and so we're excited we're
gonna take a little break probably and
breathe a little and of course we got so
many new people that joined what we
called the YouTube influencer bundle so
we're delivering all kinds of cool
coaching and training and stuff like
that to that community but you know
probably back in the fall and in
November December August actually maybe
you might do a mini one we're just so
excited to learn more about challenges
and from going through pace
of course and like learning from Pedro
we want to get better because this was
the only first challenge you know what I
mean like well I learned all these
things he gave us kind of the template
we just did what he said always smart
get a mentor and just do what they say
and and now will of course get better we
just had a meeting yesterday with the
fake media team where we wrote down a
couple pages of what we could do better
like plan ahead more you know she did
the team fix websites know how the
Facebook group is going to work and I
want to encourage you you know nothing's
perfect you don't I mean start messy be
willing to get wisdom set things up well
but to be able to move fast and break
things I got that poster on my wall from
startup vitamins because what does that
mean it means it's like move fast set it
up be willing our page is gonna break
yes are people gonna be like why I'm not
getting the link yeah it's gonna happen
like that could be messy but when you
look at all the impact I look at all the
change lives I look at the momentum I
look at what we learned and guess what
we get to then get better and sharper
and learn again and now that I've been
through it once even as I learned from
Pedro on this class we're gonna do and
take more notes I'll be like oh that
makes more sense now cuz I did it so I
want to encourage you mike says yep
learning is messy there's no way around
it and and so if you want to jump on
that class link in the description below
and if not all good but I encourage you
think about doing a challenge right now
people need hope they need encouragement
they need something to take their mind
off all the negativity in the world they
need you know to get momentum in their
health and their spirituality and their
finances or whatever it is and even just
doing a three-day challenge over a
weekend could I see we were teaching
YouTube and we didn't realize people are
gonna be like this has changed my life
you know like this was just kind of
getting connected to other people or
just kind of get me out of my shell or
just kind of like these things are
powerful and so I encourage you jump on
this marketing movement moment'
builder called challenges and if you
want some more resources I'll link those
up in the description below hit the like
button if you're getting value and
thanks for being here on this video and
click or tap the screen to watch another
video from the think marketing channel
until next time keep crushing it keep
smashing it make sure you're subscribed
to the podcast
new podcasts come out every Tuesday and
I will see you in the next video peace